Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Premier League, what's up? Das fragen wir heute wieder mal und zwar den freien Journalisten Hendrik Buchheister. Blicken mit ihm auf die englische Liga. Jetzt hier in diesem Rasenfunk-Kurzpass Nummer 96. Hendrik, sei mir sehr gegrüßt. Schön, dass du mal wieder mit dabei bist. Ja, mich auch, denn du bist ein ausgewiesener Experte der Premier League. Du lebst da drüben auf der Insel, hast einen genauen Blick darauf, verfolgst das Ganze in deiner Tätigkeit als freier Journalist. Und da würde mich jetzt einfach interessieren, wir haben zuletzt vor vier Wochen rübergeguckt nach England. Was sind denn gerade so die aktuell wichtigen Themen in der Premier League?
Ja, also das aktuell sicher größte Thema ist Manchester United und die doch allumfassende Krise dort. Also natürlich das Sportliche mit dem schlechtesten Start in der Liga seit 29 Jahren. Also in den ersten sieben Spielen gab es schon drei Niederlagen, zuletzt gegen West Ham, auch ziemlich dramatische Leistung dort. Dem Außenliga-Pokal, schon gegen Frank Lampertz, Derby County und in der Champions League dann zuletzt auch nun ziemlich müde 0-0 gegen Valencia. Und natürlich den ständigen Streitreihen, die José Mourinho anfängt mit eigentlich allem und jedem. Also sei es mit seinem Vizepräsidenten at Woodward oder mit eigentlich seiner, mehr oder weniger ganzen Mannschaft, allen vor allem natürlich Paul Pogba. Zuletzt, ganz lustig, hat es dann auch mit der Polizei in Manchester angelegt, nachdem gegen Valencia der Mannschaft so spät am Stadion ankam.
Weil es keine Eskorte gab. Gibt es ja auch nicht, weil es keine Eskorte gab. Was sind denn das für Zustände?
Was sind das für Zustände? Wurde dann hinterher auch gefragt, was war denn da los? Und hat dann so sehr in dieses Bild gepasst, was man gerade von Mourinho hat, dass er die Schuld und die Verantwortung immer bei anderen sucht. Es hat dann direkt mal auf die Polizei losgegangen, die am Tag danach meinte, nee, nee, das war aber alles so abgesprochen. Also passt so ein bisschen ins Bild. Und Manchester United und Mourinho ist gerade hier so das große Thema. Und natürlich die Frage, wie lange es Mourinho noch macht bei United. Weil wie er sich im Moment gibt und wie die Mannschaft auftritt, hat schon wieder diese Züge von diesem typischen Third-Season-Syndrome. Also was es ja auch bei Real Madrid und bei Chelsea gab, dass er in der dritten Saison dort sich mit allen anlegt, dass es sportlich bergab geht und man eigentlich nur darauf wartet, wenn man das Ganze ein Ende findet. Ja, und das ist gerade so das große Thema. Wobei, dabei auch ganz interessant, richtig viel gar nicht darauf hindeutet, dass er jetzt direkt vor ihm ausstehen könnte, weil der Verein ihn noch mehr oder weniger rückendeckend gibt. Mourinho selbst auch offenbar keine Anstalten macht, von sich aus zurückzutreten. Man hat zuletzt eher so ein bisschen den Eindruck gemacht, als würde er aus seiner Entlassung hinabhauen oder die provozieren. Aber das Problem bei Manchester United ist, dass sind wir dann in dem größeren Zusammenhang. Oder dieses Thema muss man im größeren Zusammenhang sehen, dass seit dem Weggang von Sir Alex Ferguson in fünf Jahren in diesem Klub so eine Richtung fehlt. Was für ein Fußball möchte man spielen, mit was für einer Art von Trainer, was für Spieler. Und Edward, dieser Vizepräsident, ist auch kein Fußball-Fachmann, sondern ein Finanzfachmann, also ein Marketing-Mensch. Die Aufgabe ist es, Geld mit diesem Verein zu verdienen. Das klappt halt wunderbar. Das Wortliche, hat man so ein bisschen Eindruck, ist da erst mal zweitrangig.
Was ja schon wirklich komisch ist. Also gerade im Kontrast zum anderen Verein aus Manchester, der eigentlich alles an seiner sportlichen Neuausrichtung ausgerichtet hat. Und klar, da kommt dann auch ganz viel Marketing mit dazu. Aber eher ging es darum, wir holen uns Guardiola und etablieren einen komplett neuen Stil und bauen den ganzen Verein auch in seinen Strukturen um. Bei Manchester United wirkt das eher so, als würden da ein paar Dinge brach liegen, zerfallen. Was ist denn das sportlich gesehen gerade für einen Fußball, den man sieht? Weil hier in Deutschland bekommt man vor allem mit, Mourinho hat wieder den Journalisten angepumpt und Mourinho hat das über Pokba gesagt. Und Pokba hat dieses Foto hier auf Instagram hochgeladen, aber er hatte keinen WLAN und deswegen war es gar nicht, als sie ausgeschieden waren. Also immer diese Nebenton, aber über das Sportliche, er fährt begeistert viel.
Was übrigens lustigerweise jeder Journalist, der schon mal im Autorfall versucht hat, etwas über das WLAN zu verschicken, nachvollziehen konnte, diese Erklärung von Pokba.
Tja, da hätte man ja auch mal nachfragen können. Also für die Hörer und Före ist es eben darum, dass er sich mit einem Mitspieler in einem kurzen Video auf Instagram sehr positiv und gefreut hat während des Spiels gegen Derby County. Und das Video wurde hochgeladen, nachdem man ausgeschieden war im Elfmeterschießen. Das war natürlich ungünstig, aber er sagte dann nach einem Jahr, Moment mal, ich habe das aber in der Halbzeit, glaube ich, aufgenommen.
Genau und am Tag danach gab es dann diesen, das ist wahrscheinlich auch in Deutschland jeder gesehen, diesen Videoschnipsel vom Training, wo Mourinho Pogba sehr kalt auflaufen lässt, passenderweise in den, ich glaube, den einzigen 15 Minuten in diesem Monat, in dem Kameras beim Training zugelassen waren. Also wer da an eine zufällige Fügung glaubt, das ist ja noch ein bisschen naiv, aber das war schon klar von Mourinho. Das war eine klare Machtdemonstration, diese Geschichte beim Training. Aber auch deine Frage zurück, was man für einen Fußball sieht, das ist natürlich schon dieser typische Mourinho-Fußball, der jetzt nicht auf Angriff und Spektakel ausgelegt ist, sondern immer noch sehr defensiv angelegt und eher reaktiv. Und das Ganze mittlerweile, aber das war gegen West Ham sehr auffällig, sehr unmotiviert, sehr statisch, ohne den nötigen Zug. Und man hat halt irgendwie das Gefühl, dass die Spieler, oder man kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass die Spieler den Eindruck vermitteln, sie würden für den Trainer spielen. Also das ist im Moment sehr, sehr saftloser Fußball. Und wenn diese Haltung auf den Mourinho-Fußball trifft, dann ist das Ganze halt so eine doch sehr, sehr triste Mischung.
Ja, das ist als würde, ich weiß nicht, irgendwie eine Steuererklärung, die man machen muss, auf einen Regentag fallen, wobei das würde eigentlich fast noch passen. Nee, draußen ist wunderbares Wetter und man muss ein bisschen sitzen.
Ja, genau, das ist ein schöner Vergleich. Genau, und das ist so der Fußball-Moment, den man sieht. Und was halt auffällt, ist, dass überhaupt keine, also auch in diesem Fußball überhaupt keine Idee und keine Richtung zu erkennen ist. Also bei Mourinhos Vorgängern, bei Fan Xal zum Beispiel, das war auch nicht unterhaltsam und das war nicht erfolgreich, aber da war zumindest ein Planer zu erkennen, was er vorhat, was er von Fußball spielen wollte. Das ist bei Mourinho halt gar nicht zu erkennen. Und dazu passt, dass das Ganze damit ständig wechselnd im Personal stattfindet und der Personalentscheidung trifft, wo sich die Leute hier wirklich an den Kopf fassen. Also gegen West Ham zum Beispiel hat er eine Dreierkette in der Abwehr aufgestellt, eine Dreier-Innverteidigung aufgestellt mit dem Schotten Scott McTominay, der ist eigentlich ein defensiver Mittelfeldspieler, hat diese Position noch nie gespielt. Der stand dann plötzlich gegen West Ham in der Abwehr und das Ganze ging natürlich furchtbar schief. Und während Eric Bailly, ein Spieler, den Mourinho geholt hat, auf der Bank saß, wurde hier als klares Eigentum von Mourinho auch gegen Woodward und gegen den Verein gedeutet. In dem Sinne, ihr habt mir nicht das Geld für die Spieler gegeben, die ich im Sommer haben wollte. Und jetzt seht ihr, was ihr davon habt.
Was ich aber einen interessanten Punkt finde, da haben wir auch schon in der ersten Kurzpassfolge zur Premier League kurz darüber gesprochen. Wo würdest du denn den Kader von der Stärke her einordnen in England? Denn es ist nicht mehr so wie früher, dass man sich den Kader von Manchester United ansieht und sich denkt, ja gut, das ist definitiv Platz 1 oder Platz 2 von der Stärke her in England.
Nee, definitiv nicht. Aber ich finde auch dieses Lamentieren von Mourinho, dass der Kader halt eben nicht stark genug ist, finde ich auch zu einfach. Also der Kader liegt sicher hinter Liverpool und hinter City. Und in der ersten 11 auch, würde ich sagen, hinter Tottenham und Chelsea. Aber ich finde, das ist immer noch, du hast vorne Sanches, Lukaku und dann Rashford, das ist schon immer noch sehr, sehr ordentlich. Du hast den Mittelfelden in Pogba, der halt einfach nicht das spielt, was er spielen könnte. Du hast dann Matic, der jetzt sicherlich kein Spektakelfußballer ist, aber einfach sehr solide, eine sehr, sehr gute Übersicht. Du hast Fellaini, der immer noch so eine Geheimwaffe ist, allein durch seine Kopfballstärke. Du hast den im Moment wahrscheinlich besten Torwart der Welt, zumindest was das klassische Torwatspiel angeht, also das Bälle-Abwehren, da führt an der realen Moment kein Weg vorbei. Ja, und ich finde, wenn Mourinho halt immer meckert, dass er keine Abwehrspieler hat, also er hat Abwehrspieler, hat Lindelöf, den er selbst geholt hat, für viel Geld. Er hat Fahy, den er ebenfalls selbst geholt hat, für viel Geld. Das ist schon ordentlich, die Schwäche sind sicher die Außenverteidiger, wo immer noch Valencia und Young spielen, also eigentlich ungeschulte Flügelstürmer. Er hat zuletzt öfter Luke Schorges spielt, der das schon ganz ordentlich macht. Und wir haben einen jungen Portugiesen geholt, Damien Delo. Also was ich sagen will, dieser Kader ist nicht so schlecht, wie Mourinho ihn aussehen lässt. Also mit diesem Kader kann man schon, wenn nicht um die Meisterschaft, zumindest um die Plätze, zwei bis drei mitspielen. Und das sollte auch der Anspruch sein. Das zeigt so ein bisschen dieses Grundproblem von Mourinho, dass er einfach nicht das aus der Mannschaft holt, was aus der Mannschaft rauszuholen wäre. Also dieser Vergleich wird oft angestellt, was zum Beispiel jemand wie Guardiola-Mitspielern, wie Lindelöf oder Bayi zum Beispiel anstellen würde. Das wäre definitiv mehr, als das Mourinho im Moment macht. Und wenn du dir anschaust, bei Liverpool, die Außenverteidiger, sind Andrew Robertson und Trent Alexander-Arnold. Das sind auch keine Spieler, wo man vor einem Jahr gesagt hätte, mit denen ziehst du in den Champions-League-Finale ein. Das kommt auch immer drauf an, was du draus machst. Das machen einfach sehr, sehr wenig.
Ach, ich könnte mit dir noch ewig über United sprechen, weil gerade die jüngere Vergangenheit da höchst interessant ist. Aber wir wollen ja auch noch über die anderen Mannschaften spielen. Jetzt hast du mit City und Liverpool gleich auch die beiden genannt, die am Wochenende aufeinandertreffen. Ist das jetzt gerade so aktuell in dieser Woche auch dann das wichtigste Thema, vermutlich?
Also bis gestern Abend war natürlich die Champions League das wichtigste Thema. Aber jetzt, denke ich mal, wird natürlich alles auf dieses Spiel umschwenken, weil es einfach das Topspiel ist. Also nachdem wir letztes Wochenende schon das Topspiel der Verfolger hatten, Chelsea gegen Liverpool, ist es jetzt das Spiel, in dem Liverpooler wirklich zeigen kann und auch muss, wie ernst die Ambitionen auf den Titels sind.
Also bisher hält man ja genau Schritt. Also sechs Siege ist ein Unentschieden. Beide haben jeweils nur drei Gegentore gefangen, aber City deutlich mehr Tore geschossen. 21 Tore. Ich habe auch noch mal in die Statistiken geguckt. City hatte jetzt bis jetzt in den sieben Spielen durchschnittlich 24 Schüsse aus gegnerischem Tor. Das ist ein unglaublich hoher Wert. Zum Vergleich dazu, die Bayern sind bei 18 Schüssen pro Tor, also sechs Schüsse noch mal mehr. Das ist schon noch mal ein Unterschied in der Offensivkraft.
Ja, es ist definitiv, zumal bei Liverpools mit der Offensivkraft gerade ein bisschen schwierig ist, weil Salah einfach noch nicht so in Form ist. Mane ist im Moment noch der Beste von den dreien da vorne. Und Liverpool gegen Neapel hat keinen einzigen echten Torschuss.
Ja, das war tatsächlich die schwächste Leistung von Liverpool, die ich seit ganz lange gesehen habe.
Ja, also sagen auch die Leute, die da näher dran waren gestern bei dem Spiel, dass das eigentlich eine der schlechtesten Leistungen unter Klopp war. Klopp selbst hat ja auch gesagt, wenn der Torwart der stärkste Spieler ist, dann ist das halt ein Problem und das wird ganz interessant zu sehen sein, wie Liverpool da reagiert. Weil das Programm, was sie im Moment haben, natürlich schon sehr anspruchsvoll ist mit den Spielen zuerst gegen PSG. Ja, dann gab es ein Ligaspiel gegen Southampton, aber dann gab es Chelsea im Liga-Pokal, Chelsea in der Liga, dann in Neapel und jetzt gegen Manchester City. Also das, was vorher abzusehen ist, dass die Spiele sein werden, an denen sich zeigt, in welche Richtung das für Klopps-Mannschaft gehen kann und ob es ja wirklich diesen Ansprüchen gerecht werden kann. Und da fällt das Fazit bislang halt so gemischt aus, würde ich sagen. Also PSG natürlich geschlagen und auch beeindruckend. Aber im Liga-Pokal gegen Chelsea ausgeschieden, dann in der Liga, wurde dieses 1 zu 1, später 1 zu 1, natürlich als Erfolg verbucht.
Aber viel natürlich auch erst in letzter Sekunde.
Genau, und natürlich auch als Erfolg für das, was man so Momentum nennt natürlich. Dass man das einfach behält, dass man sieht, man kann auch irgendwie in letzter Sekunde noch zurückschlagen, also ist sicher für die Moral eine gute Sache, aber im Endeffekt haben sie auch Punkte abgegeben und sehr knapp dann einen mitgenommen.
Ja, kann man sich definitiv drauf freuen. Ich habe in dieser Woche einen Podcast gehört, in dem das Wirken Pep Guardiolas in der Premier League besprochen wurde. Der war für mich überraschend negativ. Das hörte sich fast an, als ob niemand mit seinem Fußball auf der Insel etwas anfangen könne. Wenn ich mir jetzt aber allein die Dominanz-Cities jetzt schon wieder in der Liga angucke, 21 zu 3 Tore, eben die zitierten Statistiken. Ich könnte jetzt eigentlich jede Statistik zitieren, sie wäre immer beeindruckend. Man hat den meisten Ballbesitz 67 Prozent, man hat eine Passquote von 90 Prozent durchschnittlich. Also wir sehen da einfach Pep Guardiola wiederholt jetzt an Station 3, was er auch schon bei Barcelona und Bayern umgesetzt hat. Wie würdest du denn seine Wahrnehmung in England beschreiben? Ist er der Highland oder ist er der Alien, der langweiligen Kombinationsfußball spielen lässt?
Wo liegt es? Ja, vielleicht ist es so eine Mischform aus Highland und Alien. Also kann man ja vielleicht beides zusammenbringen. Also als er ankam, wurde er natürlich mit dieser üblichen Skepsis begegnet, dass man auf der Insel im Mutterland, wo alles über körperliche Härte geht, mit dem Fußball, den er spielt, halt nicht bestehen kann. Und die erste Saison hat das dann auch nahegelegt zur Zufriedenheit der großen, zur Zufriedenheit großer Teile der britischen Presse. Aber in der zweiten Saison, und das war auch, ich weiß nicht, ob du diese City-Doku auf Amazon, die mal angeschaut hast, das war so ein bisschen die Leidfrage.
Ich habe es ehrlich gesagt nicht durchgehalten, weil es einfach so glatt poliert war. Und dann dachte ich mir, mir ist meine Zeit zu schade. Also eine Folge habe ich gesehen.
Ja, ja, das ist nachvollziehbar. Aber da war ja so ein bisschen die Leidfrage, schafft er es mit seiner Art von Fußball auch England zu erobern? Und das hat er halt geschafft.
Der erste Eroberer seit 1066, was?
Also ungefähr. Na ja, und das hat er halt auch geschafft. Und das war ja auch sein klar formelierter Anspruch, dass er eben von seiner Spielweise nicht zurückweichen wird. Und das hat genauso versucht, wie er es auch in Barcelona und Bayern gemacht hat. Das ist letzte Saison gelungen und und es sieht danach aus, als würde die Saison wieder gelingen. Trotzdem ist natürlich der Fußball der City spielt. Aber trotzdem sind natürlich im Moment Liverpool und Chelsea, die deutlich interessanter anzuschauenden und auch spektakulären Mannschaften.
Weil sie nicht so dominant sind oder woran liegt das?
Ja, bei der City ist es einfach sehr sehr dominant. Da spielt der Gegner im Grunde keine Rolle und das ist schon immer sehr voraussehbar, was da passiert. Also einfach weil es natürlich auch so perfekt gespielt ist. Sie spielen den Ball von hinten raus, passen dann irgendwie Kurzpässe im Mittelfeld. Und dann kommt irgendwann, das hat man jetzt gegen Hoffenheim auch wieder gesehen, der vertikale Ball von Silva zum Beispiel, der eine ganz wichtige Rolle spielt, auf die Außen, zunehmend auch wieder Sane, der einen schwierigen Start hat, der jetzt immer besser in Form kommt. Und dann passen in die Mitte und Tor. Also das ist ja so dieses typische City-Tor. So Ball von außen zurückgespielt in die Mitte und eingeschoben. Und das ist halt irgendwie sehr, das funktioniert und es ist halt wahnsinnig gut gespielt, aber es ist jetzt so als rein neutraler Zuschauer. Ja, es ist halt sehr vorhersehbar und nicht besonders spannend. Also da guck ich mir dann irgendwie Liverpool, wo du weißt, da kracht es halt wieder, da schießt dann Starridge mal 21 Metern in Winkel. Das ist halt einfach, das schaut man sich dann halt lieber an.
Also das Überraschungsmoment fehlt einfach.
Ja, ich finde schon. Also was natürlich ein Kompliment für Guardiola ist, weil es halt irgendwie schafft, den Zufall immer mehr zu eliminieren in dem Spiel und das Fußball einfach noch immer mehr nach Plan wirkt und dieser Plan hat auch funktioniert.
Das heißt, man steht ihm dann schon vermehrt eher kritisch gegenüber.
Ich würde nicht sagen kritisch, aber ich würde schon sagen, dass die Leute sich von anderer Art Fußball besser unterhalten fühlen. Aber natürlich ist Guardiola mit den Erfolgen, die er hat und einfach diesen perfekten Fußball, den er spielt, ist halt irgendwie unangreifbar. Also man kann ihm halt schwer vorwerfen, dass der Fußball, den er spielt, einfach so gut ist, dass er immer gewinnt.
Aber wie kann denn ein Fußball von Chelsea spektakulärer sein, wenn ein Jorginho im Spiel gegen West Ham beim 0-0 180 Pässe spielt?
Ja, das Spiel fällt so ein bisschen raus. Es war schon wahnsinnig spektakulär, weil beide Mannschaften enorm hohes Tempo gegangen sind, weil beide Mannschaften enorm stark von hinten rausgespielt haben, weil beide Mannschaften den Abschluss gesucht haben. Und auch da, wenn wir so über das typische City-Tor sprechen, ich glaube, es gab bei diesem Spiel gegen Liverpool ein typisches Sarri-Tor zu sehen, dass man den Ball im Mittelfeld behauptet und dann vertikaler Ball von Kovacic war es auf Hazard und der findet dann die einzig mögliche Lücke, um den Ball irgendwie an Alisson vorbeizubringen. Und das ist, also das hat noch viel, also ich finde, der Sarri-Fußball hat noch mehr diesen Überraschungsmoment.
Und den kann man jetzt auch schon sehen nach sieben Spieltagen.
Das kann man schon sehen, also bei Chelsea ist die sind, das ist recht erstaunlich, wie schnell sie diesen Fußball von Sarri, der doch anders ist als er von Konter, also allein schon von der Formation, wie schnell sie das umsetzen und wie gut das funktioniert. Und ich würde sagen, dass Chelsea auf jeden Fall deutlich vor dem Zeitplan ist, vor dem was man vielleicht erwarten konnte. Und das ist auch die so die Haltung hier in den britischen Medien, dass es bei Chelsea wirklich erstaunlich schnell geht und erstaunlich gut funktioniert. Das liegt an den neuen Spielern, also vor allem an Jorginho, der so ein bisschen Saris, kam ja mit Sarri aus Neapel und so ein bisschen sein, diesen Sarri-Fußball auf dem Platz halt etabliert aus dieser hängenden Sechserposition draus. Ovačić auch eine extreme Verstärkung, bislang Hazard, der Moment in de Bruyne's Abwesenheit, der wahrscheinlich beste Spieler der Premier League. Und auch die Abwehr, also Antonio Rüdiger bislang mit einer sehr guten Saison, David Luiz gegen zuletzt Liverpool mit dem vielleicht in den besten Spiels, seit er wieder bei Chelsea ist. Also das funktioniert extrem gut und auch überraschend schnell extrem gut. Ein paar Fragezeichen bleiben, das wirft Sarris selbst auch auf. Also er hat vor diesem Liverpool-Spiel ein bisschen provokant gesagt, dass Liverpool mindestens ein Jahr voraus sei. Das sah dann auf dem Platz gar nicht so aus, aber ich glaube, dass Sarris noch eine gewisse Skepsis hat gegenüber diesem Verein und auch gegenüber seinem Kader. Das hat er vielleicht auch nochmal gesagt, dass es bei Chelsea in den letzten Jahren eigentlich nie Konstanz gab, dass nach einer Saison, wo du Meister warst, wo du plötzlich fast abgestiegen wärst oder zumindest deutlich zurückgefallen bist. Das war zu einmal der Fall, also nach der letzten Mourinho-Meisterschaft, nach der Meisterschaft, wo er konnte, dass die Saison danach dann, dass alles einfach nicht mehr funktioniert hat. Und ich glaube, dass er selbst noch so eine gewisse Skepsis gegenüber diesem Kader und auch vielleicht auch diesen Verein hat und deshalb so ein bisschen auf die Bremse tritt, was so die ganz große Euphorie angeht. Ich glaube, er möchte erst mal sehen, ob das wirklich auch längerfristig funktioniert. Aber so die ersten Zeichen sind wirklich gut. Das zeigen die Ergebnisse, das zeigt der Fußball. Vielleicht noch eine Anmerkung, was ein bisschen ein Fragezeichen ist in dieser neuen Sarri. Sarri eine neue Rollenspieler. Das war eigentlich der klassische tiefere Sechser. Das macht jetzt halt Jogginho. Sarri wurde deswegen nach rechts geschoben, auf so einer 8er-Mosition. Und muss sich da erst mal reinfinden, weil er eigentlich nicht so dieser Box-to-Box-Spieler ist. Da muss man mal schauen, wie sich das entwickelt. Aber insgesamt ist es bei Chelsea echt erstaunlich gut. Die sind vor dem Zeitplan und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass die Spitze ein bisschen einsortieren wollen. City ist für mich diese Saison wieder klar Favorit. Aber danach werden Liverpool und Chelsea einigermaßen gleich auffolgen. In welchem Abstand zu City muss man noch mal sehen.
Das sind auch die drei Mannschaften, die bisher noch nicht verloren haben. Also City und Liverpool einen unentschieden und ansonsten sechs Siege und Chelsea zwei unentschieden und fünf Siege. Also das läuft auch wirklich sehr gut. Ich finde auch, dass der Schmiedmann recht Chelsea-freundlich ist. Also die harten Brocken United und dann auch City. Arsenal hat man zu einem frühen Moment bekommen in der Saison, wo nur nicht alles so lief. Da würde ich gerne gleich noch kurz mit dir drüber sprechen. Das verteilt sich ganz gut über die Saison. Ich glaube, da liegt wirklich viel Potenzial für Chelsea drin.
Das stimmt. Und wo du gerade ansprichst, dass diese drei Mannschaften ungeschlagen sind, ich habe eine Statistik gelesen, dass zum ersten Mal seit 2011, so ist das, nach sieben Spieltagen, noch drei Mannschaften ungeschlagen sind. Das zeigt so ein bisschen, dass in dieser Saison wirklich eine stärkere Spitze gibt als noch in der letzten, wo es eigentlich keinen Titelkampf gab.
Ja, absolut. Wenn du jetzt sagst, es gibt schon Sarrifußball bei Chelsea, dann frage ich dich, gibt es denn auch schon Emery-Fußball bei Arsenal, die auf Platz fünf liegen gerade?
Es wird, würde ich mal sagen. Also nicht in diesem Tempo und auch nicht so unterhaltsam anzuschauen, wie das bei Chelsea ist. Aber die Ergebnisse zuletzt sprechen da für Arsenal. Du hast ja gerade den Spielplan angesprochen. Der Spielplan war jetzt nicht unbedingt Arsenal-freundlich in den ersten beiden Spielen, City und Chelsea. Die Spiele wurden dann erwartungsgemäß verloren. Aber seitdem gab es fünf Siege und die letzten zwei Mal nach einer zu Null. Das sieht von den Ergebnissen schon ordentlich aus. Einschränken muss man allerdings sagen, dass diese Siege oftmals nicht so wahnsinnig überzeugend sind und die Spiele auch anders hätten ausgehen können. Also gegen Everton vor zwei Wochen war es klar, die bessere Mannschaft. Da war es eine schießt ein Upside-Tor und gewinnt dann am Ende 2-0.
Wo war der Video-Schiedsrichter, Hendrik?
Und jetzt am Wochenende haben sie gegen Watford gespielt. Watford hat eine sehr starke Partie gemacht, hatte sehr gute Chancen, die sie nicht genutzt hat, was auch an Bernd Leno lag, der zum ersten Mal gespielt hat. Darüber können wir gleich sprechen. Und am Ende ist es ein Eigentor, was Arsenal auf Kurs bringt und am Ende noch ein Özil-Treffer. Von daher täuschen die Ergebnisse ein bisschen darüber weg, wie der Fußball ist, weil der ist noch nicht überzeugend bei Arsenal. Aber ich glaube, dass dieser Umbruch, den man bei Arsenal versucht, ist eher so eine stille Revolution. Sie haben natürlich einen neuen Trainer, nach mehr als zwei Jahrzehnten Wenger, der auch für einen gewissen Spielstil steht. Aber Arsenal hat ja zum Beispiel auf dem Transfermarkt nicht die halbe Mannschaft ausgetauscht. Die haben halt drei, vier Transfers getätigt, wo jetzt auch niemand komplett umhaut. Und jetzt gegen Watford war Torreo auch der einzige von den neuen Spielern, der in der Startelf stand, also Leno kam dann später rein. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass das Ziel bei Arsenal auch gar nicht so ist, dass von jetzt auf gleich alles komplett anders sein muss, sondern dass man schon ganz gut damit leben kann, wenn dieser Umbruch und diese Einstellung auf einen neuen Trainer, wenn das ein bisschen dauert und solange die Ergebnisse gut sind und sind sie halt im Moment, ist das dann auch okay.
Ja, dann lassen wir noch kurz über Bernd Leno sprechen. Peter Cech hat sich verletzt am Oberschenkel seitdem ist Leno fix im Kasten. Wie machte sich denn?
Genau, also das war jetzt am Wochenende gegen Watford das erste Spiel. Cech raus in der ersten Halbzeit, da war es noch Leno rein. Er hat ein richtig starkes Spiel gemacht. Er hat zwar eine richtig gute Parade gemacht, hat auch mit dem Fuß sicher gewirkt, war hinterher auch zufrieden. Er hat jetzt erstmal seine Chance. Cech heißt, es ist drei Wochen bis zu einem Monat raus. Die Zahl hat jetzt Leno erstmal und das könnte der nächste Schritt in dieser stillen Emery-Revolution sein. Man fragt sich ja schon, warum man mehr als 20 Millionen für eine Torwart ausgibt, die dann auf der Bank sitzt. Zumal, wenn der Plan ist, diesen von hinten rauszuspielen, um einen Mitspieler in der Torwart zu haben und von hinten aufzubauen, das kann Cech halt nicht. Das hat man in den ersten Spielen gesehen, wo er sich irgendwie die Bälle, gab ein Spiel gegen City gleich am Anfang, er hat den Ball sich fast direkt ins eigene Tor geschoben, gab Szenen, wo er den Ball direkt zum Gegner gespielt hat. Also er ist einfach, Cech ist einfach kein Torwart, der dieses von hinten heraus Spielen beherrscht. Das kann halt Leno viel besser, und deswegen hat man sich schon ein bisschen gefragt, wann kommt denn der Leno jetzt mal, wann spielt er denn endlich? Und jetzt ist es halt eher durch den Missgeschick oder einfach durch die Verletzung von Cech dazu gekommen, dass er jetzt mal spielt. Und er hat das erste Spiel gut gemacht, er spielt jetzt erst mal, und ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass er dann danach auch im Tor bleibt. Ich kann natürlich auch verstehen, dass man Cech, der einfach enorm verdienstvoller Spieler ist, sich nichts dazu verschulden kommen lassen, enorm loyaler Spieler, dass man den nicht einfach so absägt. Das ist auch klar, aber dieser Wechsel im Tor, der musste irgendwann kommen und möglicherweise ist es es jetzt.
Wer sehen möchte, was Bernd Leno am Ball kann, da kann auch mal gerade gucken, was Leverkusen jetzt unter Lukas Radetz gemacht hat. Das ist eine ganz andere Art und Weise des Spielaufbaus und da gibt es auch durchaus mal den einen oder anderen Pass und Abstoß ins Seiten aus. Also da fehlt Leverkusen ein bisschen was, was Arsenal jetzt im Spiel hat. Mal sehen, ob er sich durchsetzen kann. Wir deutschen Zuschauer und Fußballfans haben ja immer noch ein bisschen den Blick auf Huddersfield. Da sieht es jetzt in dieser Saison viel schlechter aus, als in der letzten, aktuell letzter Platz mit nur zwei Punkten. Wie macht sich denn das Team von David Wagner?
Ja, schwierig, also es war abzusehen, dass diese zweite Saison natürlich deutlich schwieriger wird als die erste.
Immer die schwerste, genau.
Immer die schwerste. Was allein schon daran liegt, dass die Mannschaften, die aufgestiegen sind, jetzt keine klassischen Aufsteiger sind, also vielleicht auch drüber reden, Fulham und gerade Wolves sehr ambitioniert. Also da war klar, dass die wahrscheinlich nicht direkt gegen den Abstieg spielen und dass die nicht direkt hinterher, also dass die sich vielleicht sogar eher vor Huddersfield einordnen. Von daher Huddersfield schon mit einer schwierigen Ausgangslage. Und das Spiel ist natürlich immer noch das Gleiche, was man auch aus der letzten Saison kennt. Und das Problem ist einfach die Treffen des Torens. Also die haben in dieser Saison noch kein Heimtor geschossen. Ich glaube auch Instagram hat erst drei Treffer erzielt in der letzten Saison. Die Mannschaft mit den wenigsten Toren zusammen mit West Brom, dem tabellen Letzten. Also dieses Problem hatten sie in der letzten Saison schon. Und das hat sich in die neue Saison mit übertragen. Die Stimmung dort ist immer noch gut. Also ich war jetzt am Wochenende beim Spiel gegen Spurs, die Leute stehen immer noch hinter der Mannschaft. Es ist laut im Stadion, die Leute feiern die Mannschaft, auch wenn dort verloren wird. Und damit Wagner sagt auch selbst, der macht sich überhaupt keine Gedanken, weil der Fußball ist gut und kann man ihm auch ein Stück weit zustimmen. Weil zum Beispiel gegen Spurs am Wochenende waren sie schon, haben sie gut mitgespielt, hatten ganz ordentliche Chancen, hätten auch ein oder andere Tor machen können. Aber machen sie halt nicht. Und ich fand in der letzten Saison war Huddersfields Stärke eigentlich immer, dass sie, also auch da hatten sie mal so Phasen, wo sie mal fünf Spiele nicht gewonnen haben oder wo es mal eine längere Niederlage-Serie gab, wie das zu erwarten ist bei einem Aussteiger. Aber dann haben sie es halt immer geschafft, wenn es dann wirklich eng wurde und wenn sie wirklich einen Sieg brauchten, haben sie es dann auch mal wieder eingeholt. Also die wirklich wichtigen Spiele haben sie dann immer gewonnen und das gelingt ihnen bislang halt noch nicht. Und sie haben halt auch schon so gegen Cardiff gespielt, gegen Burnley. Wenn man sagen würde, wenn man in der Liga bleiben will, gegen solche Mannschaften, müsste man halt mal gewinnen. Das klappt da bislang noch nicht.
Andererseits sind es auch nur drei Punkte auf den Nicht-Abstiegsrang. Also dadurch, dass die Spitze gerade so stark ist, das was du vorhin angesprochen hast, merkt man auch, dass das Ende der Tabelle sehr eng noch beieinander ist, weil sie sind sich alle darin einig, dass sie gar nicht oder erst einmal gewonnen haben, die letzten sechs.
Ja genau, also von daher ist natürlich, und ich glaube das erklärt auch so ein bisschen Wagnassenheit, da ist natürlich noch nichts verloren. Und wenn du jetzt mal ein Spiel gewinnst, dann stehst du plötzlich schon wieder über den Strich. Von daher ist Huddersfield auch gut beraten, nicht in Panik zu verfallen, weil die halt wissen, dass jede Saison in der Premier League eigentlich mehr ist, was man erwarten kann. Aber natürlich müssen irgendwann die Punkte her. Und mit jedem Spiel, was so läuft, wie z.B. das gegen Tottenham, wo sie gut mitspielen, wo sie Chancen haben, wo sie aber schon wieder nicht treffen, dass sie dann verlieren, ist natürlich irgendwann das Risiko, dass die Spieler dann auch irgendwann resignieren, weil sie halt sehen, es reicht dann doch nicht. Von daher glaube ich, ist es schon extrem wichtig, dass Huddersfield das nächste Mal das Spiel gewinnt.
Gut, wir werden es verfolgen. Als letztes würde mich noch interessieren, was sind denn gerade so für dich, wenn wir haben jetzt wieder mal so über die klassischen Mannschaften gesprochen? Gibt es noch irgendwelche Außenseite, die dich überraschen oder muss ich mir Spiele von bestimmten Mannschaften unbedingt angucken? Ich habe zum Beispiel gesehen, Crystal Palace ist auf Platz 2 der gewonnenen Dribblings pro Partie. Kann ich mir jetzt als Außenstehende überhaupt nicht erklären, warum, aber wen gibt es da, den du noch irgendwie erwähnenswert findest?
Ja, also erwähnenswert finde ich, ich würde noch zwei Sachen in die Runde schmeißen. Zum einen die schon angesprochenen Wolves, über die ihr in der letzten Folge schon mal gesprochen hattet, die mit den guten Kontakten zu Ronaldo-Berater Mendes sich eine Mannschaft zusammengestellt haben, mit einem sehr starken portugiesischen Einfluss, mit einem portugiesischen Trainer, Espirito Santo, ein Spielarm wie Mourinho oder Neves, die für einen Aufsteiger sehr ambitioniert sind, auch sehr ambitionierten, offensiven, schnellen Fußballspielen und im Moment auf Platz 9 stehen und die sicherlich, dafür, dass sie ein Aufsteiger sind, nicht nur das Ziel an die Klasse zu halten, sondern Wolves ist auf jeden Fall ein Klub, dem ich zutrauen würde, so die Rolle zu spielen, wie es Burnley in der vergangenen Saison gemacht hat. Ah, okay. Um diesen siebten Platz zu spielen, der in der Premier League immer so ein bisschen, der ist der, der so allen anderen Mannschaften offen steht, die jetzt nicht zu den Top 6 gehören. Also die Top 6 sind immer ziemlich zementiert, bekannterweise, und der siebte Platz ist dann so der, wo man dann mal mit einer überraschenden Saison landen kann. Um diesen Platz, glaube ich, werden Wolves auf jeden Fall mitspielen.
Müssen sie aber noch ein bisschen am Ziel wasserschrauben, oder? Ich sehe sie bei den Schüssen pro Spiel auf Platz 4 hinter City, Chelsea und Liverpool. Aber bei den Toren, als du gerade gesagt hast, sie spielen einen offensiven, tollen Fußball, wollte ich schon einwerfen. Ja, aber nur 8 zu 6 Tore nach sieben Spieltagen. Das klingt jetzt gar nicht so. Das klingt eher nach Schalke, als nach City. Sorry, Schalke-Fans.
Ja, aber das finde ich für einen, also allein schon als Aufsteiger, so mit dieser Haltung in die Liga zu gehen. Wir stellen uns jetzt nicht hinten rein und warten ab Konter, sondern wir spielen mit und versuchen, das Spiel selbst zu gestalten und die Spiele zu haben, das finde ich schon bemerkenswert. Dieses Modell, was dahinter steht, kann man natürlich kritisch sehen. Die Liga hat sich damit mal befasst mit diesen Kontakten zu Mendelssohn, hat festgestellt, da gibt es kein Problem. Aber natürlich kann man das kritisch sehen. Ich glaube, in Deutschland würde so ein Modell auch deutlich kritischer gesehen werden als hier, wo man solchen innovativen Ansätzen sehr offen gegenübersteht. Das zweite Team, das ich gerne erwähnen würde, weil man es so gar nicht erwartet, ist West Ham, die die ersten vier Spiele verloren haben und jetzt aber zuletzt dreimal ungeschlagen, unter anderem Everton und zuletzt auch Manchester United geschlagen haben und die haben eine wirklich spannende Mannschaft, also mit Philipp Andersen, der ein sensationelles Tor gemacht hat gegen Manchester United mit der Hacke, mit Jamo Lenko, den man ja noch aus Dortmund an den Tagen kennt, und auch Anautovic, der es wirklich so ein bisschen geschafft hat, wie es aussieht. Also das ist so die Angriffsreihe. Anautovic, der es so ein bisschen geschafft hat, sich irgendwie auf den Fußball zu konzentrieren und wirklich zu sehen, worauf es bei so einer Profi-Karriere ankommt. Wir erinnern uns an seine Bremer Tage, ihm haben wir es ein bisschen schwierig gefallen. Aber Anautovic ist ein absolut wichtiger Spieler. Er hat schon vier Tore geschossen, ist wahnsinnig stark, wenn es darum geht, den Ball abzuschirmen und sich gegen Gegenspieler durchzusetzen. Er strahlt auch ein wahnsinniges Selbstvertrauen. Das ist eine spannende Entwicklung dazu, eine solide Defensive mit Fabianski im Tor, den sie geholt haben, mit einer guten Innenverteidigung, die auch neu ist. Ja, und das ist nach diesem schwachen Start, nach diesem Chaos, was es auch in der letzten Saison bei West Ham gab, ist das im Moment zumindest mit den letzten drei Spielen eine absolut positive und auch überraschende Entwicklung. Also da lohnt es sich auf jeden Fall, ein Auge drauf zu haben.
Was für ein Kader, was für ein Kader. Da hast du schon genannt, aber dann hast du noch Sabaleta hinten drin, Reece Oxford und vorne, die gerade noch gar nicht so die große Rolle spielen, Chicharito und noch nicht eingesetzt, weil verletzt, aber Andy Carroll hast du ja auch noch so ein richtiges Tier. Also und 20 gelbe Karten in sieben Spielen, damit unangefochten Tabellenführer in der...
Ja, ja, genau, da wird dann so ein bisschen das alte West Ham auch gewahrt, was da verloren gegangen ist durch dieses raue West Ham, was da verloren gegangen ist durch diesen Umzug ins Olympiastadion. Genau, und auch ein sehr spannendes Talent, Declan Rice, 19 Jahre alt, auf dem man auf jeden Fall auch ein Auge haben sollte.
Ach Mensch, schön. Das macht einem immer wieder Lust, auf die Premier League zu gucken. Danke dir, Hendrik, das hat mir wieder großen Spaß gemacht. Und dann bin ich mal gespannt, wie es sich jetzt dann unter anderem Liverpool gegen City am Wochenende schlägt. Das ist am Sonntagabend um 17.30 Uhr dieses Spiel. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das könnte man sich eventuell in einem Secondscreen noch reinziehen. Hendrik, danke dir, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst. Hendrik Buchheister, freier Journalist, h--Buchheister auf Twitter. Und vielen Dank auch euch für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Anders als die Premier League. Wie finanzieren wir uns über Spenden? Wie ihr das machen könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de Und wie immer gilt die Ansage, auch ein oder zwei Euro im Monat reichen, wenn es genügend von euch machen. Denkt mal drüber nach, würde uns sehr freuen. Ansonsten hören wir uns im nächsten Kurzpass oder in der nächsten Schlusskonferenz. Bis dahin eine gute Zeit, ciao!